but when it just a complete shutout I I
don't like the rematches I don't like it
would've been better if Izzy got knocked
out in the first second of that fight to
get in order to get the rematch that
being said I also think Izzy needs a
break I think he's way too active at the
fight at the level he's fighting at I
think he puts too much emphasis on
social media I think he's too worried
about what people say I think he needs
to step back recuperate let the division
do its thing get some more contenders in
there because you've beat everybody let
Sean Strickland get his shine let's say
Sean Strickland builds himself up even
more whoever they decide to throw him
next and then jump back in slow down all
good still one of the best to ever do it
you got to be careful not to be a
prisoner of the moment I see a lot of
people told you is he's not that good
told you is he's not one of the greats
he out of your freaking mind to say is
he's not one of the greatest
middleweights of all time he's dumb
you're just dumb